solution UCLA never quit in this game
I'd send it over to Lauren shahadi
comes what is it about
it they're two really really really
really good teams and they both got
hearts of Champions and so it's
impossible to put them away I knew we
were not we still had some work to do
when we got up seven there but this
guy's made so many big shots for us I
knew if I called his number he delivered
is that what
if he could go downhill was fine but I
kind of knew if he sized up one of those
threes we've worked on that in practice
all the time and he usually makes that
shot and he did congratulations
wow a moment in time what was going
through your mind when you left your
hands oh I mean as soon as it came off
it looked like it was online and I mean
I mean like Jose we work on that blade
literally you know in practice all the
time and and our student in practice and
y'all may be joking around sometimes but
but here we are and it mattered today
congratulations you did this Drew what
does that mean
oh God I am the number one Jillian
Strother fan in the planet no one's a
bigger fan of them than me man everyone
in this country is a big Drew Timmy fan
you are a legend what is it about these
lights that makes you shine brightest
man it just brings the best out of us as
competitors I mean UCLA is a hell of a
team we've had a we've had a big rivalry
you know throughout my career here and
just to be able to you know get hit in
the mouth and come back and respond man
that's all you've been doing all year we
just fight keep fighting keep swinging
and don't give up and we came back and
thank God we pulled it out
to your Batman what about Malachi
tonight
man he doesn't get enough credits he
deserves he was the national Player of
the Year in his conference for a reason
I mean we're so lucky to have them and
what he does for this team man I mean he
doesn't get enough credits he he's got
some big kahunas on him and he stepped
up and uh we couldn't be more proud of
him you were drawing your mustache when
you were down 13. what's that all about
true Timmy so what you were drawing your
mustache when you were down 13 a little
inspiration yeah hey I mean I gotta do
whatever I can to fire this team up and
fire myself up and if people will have a
problem with that then you know they can
go uh show somewhere else I love it
you're everything that's right about the
game the moment is yours congratulations
Kevin he's very shy I can tell that
Lauren thank you the three-time
All-America the two-time West Coast
Conference player of the year
real tip off
three seed Gonzaga four seed UConn
Saturday 8 49 Eastern